le centre ville c'est à la fois des
commerces mais aussi des habitants et
d'après nous il semble plus important de
développer d'autres moyens de
déplacements alternatifs à la voiture
comme donc les transports en commun
c'est une de nos propositions
principales de mettre en place des
transports en commun gratuits
notre stratégie c'est vraiment de tout
faire pour arriver à pouvoir extraire la
voiture du centre-ville pour justement
libérer les espaces et après essayer de
les aménager la voiture au coeur de vie
s'éteint c'est ce qu'on appelle un
serpent de mer en terme de débats je
crois qu'il faut qu'une fois poursuivre
nous puissions le leur essai signifie
qu'aujourd'hui il faut redonner ce qu'on
appelle le désir de la ville re
découvrir la ville et c'est tout l'objet
d'ailleurs des des projets d'aménagement
urbain que je que je peux voir les
qu'une vraie réflexion sur la place que
rob de la voiture mais certains aussi la
place fed
en complément aux autres modes de
déplacement ce qu'on appelle les
déplacements doux à la fois la marche le
vélo d'autres modes de déplacement il
s'agit pas de supprimer totalement la
voiture des gens en ont vraiment besoin
mais retirer un peu la place de la
voiture au centre ville pour constater
qu'il y a quand même offert beaucoup de
places qui sont exclusivement des
parkings faut faire un choix et je pense
que si on veut vraiment promouvoir sous
centre-ville et le mettre en valeur
il faut faire le choix dexter
progressivement la voiture et de
d'envisager donc là la piétonnisation
ponctuel ou permanent d'un hyper centre